avec un certain joe ingles qu'on se
plaît à regarder à la télé jordi island
ou koh lanta mais on a d'autres qui
divise beaucoup plus quand les migrants
sont bloqués à calais on parle de jungle
jungle ça reste les la jungle on sait
tous que c'est c'est une forêt tropicale
avec plein d'animaux sauvages à
indomptables des plantes exotiques
mortels et des aborigènes qui te vise à
la sarbacane quoi alors c'est pas un
endroit fait pour vivre ça fait pour
survivre
du coup la jungle de calais que vous
avez vues dans tous les jt c'est près de
6000 migrants bloqués près de la
frontière anglaise à quelques kilomètres
du centre ville de calais et si on en
parle autant en ce moment c'est suite à
l'accélération des décisions de justice
entraînant l'évacuation d'une partie du
camp et sa destruction au tractopelle
mais un fort courant dans le détail
c'est important qu'on se pose et qu'on
explique ce que c'est que cette jungle
et pourquoi elle existe déjà on peut
l'avoir simplement comme un camp de
migrants et réfugiés qui s'est installée
au fur et à mesure à proximité de la
ville de calais et ça date pas d'hier
sauf si vous regardez cette vidéo en
1999 ce qui n'aurait absolument aucun
sens ce qui s'est passé à ce moment là
c'est qu'il ya eu en fait un afflux de
personnes provenant du kosovo en guerre
et qu'on a créé un centre d'accueil à
sangatte
une commune qui à côté de calais du coup
les tailles a réquisitionné un hangar de
27 mille mètres carrés appartenant à
eurotunnel et la gestion du centre a été
confié à la croix rouge
alors l'idée c'est que les migrants
puissent attendre dans le hangar le
temps qu'on leur donne les autorisations
nécessaires
sauf que c'est devenu de plus en plus
difficile d'avoir une autorisation
donc ça a bloqué on se retrouve à 1800
personnes dans un centre prévu pour
accueillir 800 personnes
imaginez la crise du logement à paris
sauf qu'il n'ya pas de logement et que
c'est pas pareil pour vous donner une
idée en trois ans sangatte a vu passer
près de 68 mille migrants il ya du
passage et ça ça dure jusque 2002 après
on ferme le centre de sangatte et ont
détruit parce que on a enfin trouvé une
solution
et donc il y avait plus besoin du centre
voilà enfin c'est ce que j'aurais aimé
dire mais non 1 les politiques ont juste
détruit pour le symbole aura été la
fermeture du centre à laisser place à ce
que l'on appelle la jungle de calais
donc depuis la création du camp le
problème n'a jamais été réglé ça a juste
changé de nom ce qui fait que ça
embrouiller l'opinion publique c'est le
retour des réfugiés en masse qui est
nouveau par contre il ya une question
que
se pose c'est un as du saint tropez de
quiberon des [ __ ] de stations de ski
et paris plage pour qu'ils vont tous à
calais quoi en fait attention spoilers
ils sont pas là pour prendre du bon
temps
eux ils veulent aller en angleterre 46%
des migrants calaisiens ont déclaré
avoir suivi les conseils de leur
communauté
dans ce choix de destinations et 38% ou
un membre de leur famille installée en
angleterre
donc oui en gros le royaume uni attire
beaucoup plus les migrants que la france
1 ils ont de la famille là-bas et il
parle anglais c'est plus simple d'y
trouver un job
du coup ils n'ont pas pour but de
s'intégrer en france c'est une partie du
problème aussi donc on va des
populations qui rentre en europe par
plein de portes différentes et qui se
retrouvent bloqués à la frontière
anglaise chez nous alors pour dresser le
tableau il ya peut-être cinq mille trois
cent cinquante personnes en train de
faire du camping près de la mer du nord
on est très loin d'un camp de vacances
info déjà imaginé un camp entre un
marais une autoroute
les familles sont dans des tentes les
sanitaires non de sanitaires que le non
est ce qui sert d'épicerie mais là que
pour les nécessités
parce que oui dans ces conditions je
peux concevoir que le red bull soit
nécessité en plus de ce qu'on voit là
ils baignent dans un environnement assez
violent et à tous les niveaux violences
policières violence de militants
d'extrême-droite violences entre
migrants
la situation est complexe et notamment
pour les femmes et les enfants
tu as plusieurs associations comme
médecins du monde ou médecins sans
frontières qui ont dénoncé de graves
atteintes à la santé et aux droits des
femmes et à des violences multiples
viols prostitution grossesses non
désirées infections sexuellement
transmissibles et du coup il ya des
zones sanctuarisées et sécurisée qui
leur sont maintenant réservées
tu as même certains pères seuls avec
leurs enfants qui les ont confiés à des
mères dans ces sanctuaires afin de les
préserver en france quoi et depuis
plusieurs mois la situation s'envenime
les migrants s'appuie sur des réseaux de
passeurs pour tenter de rejoindre
l'angleterre
sauf que les passeurs et sont organisés
ils profitent de la situation ils
squattent eux aussi la zone les mecs
développe un véritable business
estimée entre trois et six milliards
d'euros sur l'ensemble de la zone europe
alors le chiffre peut paraître abstrait
mais vous parlera peut-être mieux si je
vous dis que le pib du monaco était de
5,32 milliards en 2014 c'est c'est juste
hallucinant
les mecs vont même jusqu'à développer
des filières low cost à 500 euros le
passage vers l'angleterre
à bord d'un camion qui leur appartient
évidemment pas et je serais pas surpris
que parfois ce soient eux mêmes qui les
conduisent c'est le ryanair un petit peu
de l'immigration clandestine
lorsque vous avez sûrement déjà vu des
images de migrants qui essaient de
passer vers le royaume uni en montant
dans des camions des ferries voire même
en essayant de s'introduire dans le
tunnel sous la manche et bars et souvent
via ses réseaux de passeurs et c'est
assez fréquent puisque les vues transmis
tentative d'intrusion en dix mois
d'après eurotunnel et franchement je
comprends cette volonté de partir le
problème c'est que la jungle de calais
bah c'est pas ça ne dit mot angie quoi
on sent pas en faisant 15.6 les points
de passage sont bloqués et la vie doit
s'organiser sur place du coup
inévitablement
ça impacte directement la population
locale parce que faut pas oublier que
cette situation a fait peser surtout
calais et ses environs
les chauffeurs de camion par exemple pas
ils doivent vérifier chaque centimètre
carré de leur camion passer par des
procédures de vérification des douanes
beaucoup plus complexe bref et se
retrouve parfois confrontés à des
attaques et sarah hanffou certaines quoi
j'avais pensé qu un bord de route puisse
avoir une si mauvaise ambiance et à
calais c'est pire c'est la vie de la
population qui est directement touché la
maire de calais en porte parole parle
d'une prise d'otage des calaisiens ce
qui se comprend parce que les arguments
sont nombreux
ça va du sentiment d'insécurité
l'impression d'un flux dans les hôpitaux
à cause des conditions de vie dans les
camps et surtout que les gens sont à
bout quoi ils subissent le problème
depuis 15 ans les mecs alors qu'elle et
ses 72 mille habitants on parlait de
6000 migrants tout à l'heure c'est un
peu moins de 10%
bien évidemment ça crée des tensions
pendant ce temps là certains regrettent
le passé leur vie dans une ville joyeuse
ne nous emballons pas mais c'est vrai
que il ya toute une population qui
vivait grâce au tourisme
aujourd'hui les commerçants et
restaurateurs sont dans cette situation
difficile et subissent l'image de zones
de guerre perpétuellement véhiculée par
les médias
en seulement quelques mois le secteur de
la restauration a teminé de 40% et les
commerces de détail de 20%
c'est beaucoup et du coup bah qu'est ce
qui se passe dans une zone qui se sent
délaissée depuis 15 ans mais les gens
essaient de prendre les choses en main
et les manifestations anti ou pro
migrants à calais deviennent fréquentes
comme sur cette séquence par exemple qui
a pesé il ya plusieurs semaines et on
voit un habitant sortir avec son fusil
donc si on résume pour l'instant on a
des migrants et des réfugiés empaqueter
qui vit dans des conditions horribles
des calaisiens qui sont à bout et une
situation qui s'envenime et s'enlise
c'est hyper complexe
en fait pour bien comprendre calais il
va falloir dézoomer un peu et regarder
le problème dans sa globalité
quel est ce une conséquence directe de
la crise des migrants qui secoue
l'europe depuis des années 2010 un bien
résumée ici par cette carte que je vous
mets en descriptions l'organisation
interne en salle pour les migrants l'om
annonce aujourd'hui que depuis janvier
2016 plus de cent mille migrants sont
arrivés en europe via la méditerranée en
2015 ce chiffre n'avait été atteint
qu'en juin alors que c'était déjà une
année on a vécu une explosion du nombre
d'arrivées et sur ces 100 milles plus de
90 % qui sont arrivés en grèce qui
évidemment pas les écrire lorsque je
vous rappelle que les grecs sont pas au
top niveau tune et moyens d'accueil
du coup les proportions de ce problème
elles sont juste énormes en fait qu'elle
est à un point de crispation autour
d'une crise bien plus globale et cette
crise globale
elle est avant tout une crise politique
l'europe est archi divisés sur la
question
l'allemagne pour des raisons
principalement économique
démographique a choisi d'accueillir plus
d'un million de migrants avant de
freiner le rythme des entrées et elle
est favorable en plus un système de
répartition par quotas alors que la
france par exemple à des contrats et à
d'autres comme la hongrie qui veulent
même pas entendre parler de migrants
comme n'y a pas de décision commune les
décisions se font au niveau des
différents pays et chaque décision d'un
pays a des conséquences dans les pays
voisins par exemple en prévision de la
possible évacuation d'une partie de la
jungle de calais la belgique a rétabli
le contrôle aux frontières avec la
france
il ya quelques semaines ou encore la
macédoine un petit pays qui fait la
salade qui vient de décider de ne plus
laisser rentrer les migrants afghans
raison les gens à rester en grèce créant
un nouveau méga calais en grèce ce qui
est beaucoup moins drôle que le jeter à
mykonos et c'est pour ça qu'un camp deux
fois plus grand que calais est né à une
domini où s'entassent désormais plus de
11 mille migrants c'est énorme et cet
effet domino de frontières et va jusqu'à
la turquie point de passage obligé pour
les migrants et réfugiés syriens
notamment et du coup ça bloque aussi et
il ya aujourd'hui plus de 2 millions de
syriens c'est-à-dire 10% la population
de la syrie d'avant guerre qui vivent en
turquie et en jordanie
pour vous donner une idée les camps en
jordanie ça ressemble à ça 80000 syrien
dans le camp de sentani en jordanie
tu prends calais qui multiplie par dix
ses actus réalise que calais à côté ben
c'est pas une jungle c'est un terrain
mini golf dans le lot et garonne
donc moi quand j'entends les migrants
dehors ou fermons nos frontières je
trouve ça complètement déconnecté de la
réalité qu elle s est pas nouveau c'est
un phénomène qu'on a connus qu'on
connaîtra à nouveau tant qu aura des
guerres à nos portes
c'est mathématique quoi ces gens là
c'est un théorème alors prends tu as une
guerre et que tu as une partie de la
population civile qui est touché par
cette population a fui son pays pour
d'autres territoires où elle a des
attaches
par contre c'est pas parce que c'est
logique que c'est souhaitable ni pour
les calaisiens mais surtout pour les
migrants qui se tape des trajets
incroyablement dangereux pas donc voilà
peut-être qu'on peut y faire quelque
chose et je prend pas trop de risque en
disant que c'est ni le démantèlement des
camps et le relogement des personnes
concernées ni le changement de politique
la gestion des frontières extérieures de
l'ue eux qui à eux seuls vont régler ce
problème de manière durable et la preuve
c'est que à peine une partie la jungle
évacuée
un autre camp vient d'être ouvert à
grande-synthe pour l'anecdote il avait
une capacité de 1500 personnes et il
était complet en une semaine
donc on a une situation qui n'est pas
souhaitable et aucune solution simple
et bien pour trouver des pistes c'est
tout bête on va reprendre certains de
nos problèmes déjà celui des passeurs
qui à mon sens c'est assez grave puisque
indirectement ils alimentent cet afflux
fait que c'est dans leur intérêt que les
gens aient la volonté d'aller en
angleterre
du coup si on arrive à démanteler les
réseaux de passeurs en atténue le
phénomène qu'on observe à calais la même
manière il faut sensibiliser les
migrants à la réalité de calais et la
réalité de la frontière anglaise parce
qu'il ya de nombreux migrants qui
regrette d'être venu et veulent rentrer
chez eux
ça c'est aussi un vrai problème
l'information ensuite un autre souci
c'est la mésentente européenne il
faudrait que les pays d'europe calme
leur ego nationaux respectifs pour
mettre en place une réponse plus
coordonnée parce que pour l'instant
l'europe arrive à se mettre d'accord
uniquement pour aller demander à la
turquie de retenir les migrants en
échange des aides financières et autres
concessions ont toujours pour tout le
reste l'europe se déchirent pourtant
répartir quelques millions de personnes
au sein d'une europe qui compte plus de
500 millions d'habitants ça semble pas
être hallucinant et c'est hyper dommage
parce que l'europe c'est fait pour des
problèmes comme ça c'est sur ce genre de
truc qu'on attend non seulement l'europe
ne prend pas cette direction mais en
plus elle prend la direction contraire
en se fracturant plus que jamais sur des
questions identitaires gens s'occupent
en s'occupant pardon comme elle peut
avec des briques site c'est le fait que
la grande bretagne sort de l'europe où
la crise de l'euro les sanctions contre
la russie entre autres
enfin bref autant de sujets qui divisent
les opinions politiques et font monter
les extrêmes affaiblissant les
démocraties européennes en les empêchant
de parler d'une voix forte le problème
de calais là pas de chance c'est un
problème qui s'étend sur des dizaines
d'années qui est assez local tous les
ingrédients sont là pour que les gens
l'oublient
s'il ya une vraie solution elle est bien
à l'extérieur de calais et elle est dans
la paix un calais nous fait prendre
conscience que nous vivons dans un monde
globalisé même au niveau migratoire
malgré les frontières apparente et ce
qui se passe dans un pays à l'autre bout
du monde ça peut avoir des répercussions
sur un village au nord de la france ces
problèmes là ils devraient nous
concerner davantage avant que ça prenne
l'ampleur on voit là parce que qu'on le
veuille ou non on vit dans un monde où
de plus en plus jusque dans les faits le
problème des autres bah c'est notre
problème aussi j'espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu big up aux associations qui
sont sûrs qu'elles mêmes ils font un
formidable
je voulais remercier aussi les types
heures qui soutiennent le projet vous
pouvez vous aussi soutenir le projet sur
typiquement comme cela chez cirrus north
merci de me suivre sur facebook
facebook.com un slasher isnard twitter
tout à fait pas comme ça et ce match at
love peace